BOOSTERS.
BACK TO "HANNITY."
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
--
>> Sean: FORMER FBI AGENT IS
COMING FORWARD TO EXPLAIN WHY
SHE LEFT THE BUREAU AND SOUNDING
THE ALARM OVER HOW DEEPLY
POLARIZED THINGS HAVE BECOME
WITHIN THE FBI.
THIS SHOULD BE THE WORLD'S
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
THIS NO LONGER IS.
NICOLE PARKER LEFT THE BUREAU
AFTER 13 YEARS.
SHE WORKED ON HIGH-PROFILE
CASES.
THE PARKLAND SCHOOL SHOOTING AND
AIRPORT SHOOTING AND THE PIPE
BOMB CASE AND PONZI SCHEMES AND
SO MUCH MORE.
SHE SAYS THE BUREAU LOST THE
TRUST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SHE WRITES.
SHE SAID THERE WAS A SHIFT IN
RECRUIT PRACTICES AND LOWERING
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS WHICH
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS PERFORMANCE.
IN CLOSING SHE WRITES:
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE, FORMER FBI
SPECIAL AGENT NICOLE PARKER.
THANKS FOR COMING.
YOU WERE WORKING FOR MERRILL
LYNCH ON THE TROOP FLOOR OF THE
WORLD TRADE CENTER.
>> CORRECT.
I HEARD THE FIRST PLANE CRASH
INTO THE NORTH TOWER.
I RAN TO THE WINDOW AND
WITNESSED THE SECOND PLANE
CRASHING INTO TOWER 2.
THAT DAY CHANGED MY LIFE.
IF YOUR YEAR THERE WERE 55,000
APPLICATION.
YOU WENT THROUGH 6 MONTHS OF
TRAINING.
>> CORRECT.
>> OKAY.
WHAT WAS THE FBI LIKE THEN AND
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I CAME TO THE FBI BECAUSE I
LOVE AMERICA.
I WANTED TO SERVE THIS COUNTRY.
I KNEW ON 9-11.
I CAME IN.
IT WAS AMAZING TO JOIN THE FBI.
I WORKED WITH THE FINEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST IN THE FBI.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS.
THESE ARE OUTSTANDING AND
WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
WE WERE JUST GETTING IN THERE
AND FIGHTING CRIME AND PUTTING
BAD PEOPLE BEHIND BARS.
THAT'S WHY I CAME.
I NOTICED THROUGH THE COURSE OF
MY CAREER, THE TRAJECTORY OF THE
FBI CHANGED.
IT SEEMED TO HAVE BEEN MORE IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS MORE
THAN EVER.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT I STARTED
TO WONDER IS THIS THE FBI I
SIGNED ON TO?
THE AMAZING HEROES IN THE FBI
THEY ARE STILL THERE AND DOING
THE HARD WORK.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THAT HARD
WORK IS GETTING DROWNED OUT BY
THE NEGATIVITY HAPPENING.
>> Sean: I COULD NOT BELIEVE IN
2016 THE FBI SAID IN EARLY
OCTOBER AFTER THEY WERE WARNED
IN AUGUST NOT TO TRUST THE DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER OF HILLARY
CLINTON.
THEY 2016 THEY SENT AGENTS TO
INTERVIEW CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND
OFFER HIM A MILLION DOLLARS TO
DO CORROBORATE IT.
WE CAN'T AND DOESN'T GET THE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IT WAS UNVERIFIABLE.
THEY WEREN'T TO A FISA COURT AND
SAYS VERIFIED.
THEY COULD NOT VERIFY IT.
AT THAT MOMENT, THEY PUT THEIR
FINGERS ON THE SCALE OF THAT
ELECTION.
THEY HAD HUNTER'S LAPTOP IN
2019.
YET THEY WERE TALKING TO THE FBI
LEAKLY TALKING TO ALL BIG TECH
COMPANIES.
THERE MIGHT BE DISINFORMATION
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
DID YOU SEE THAT TYPE OF
POLITICS.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE THE PEOPLE
WORKING CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WE ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
AMERICANS.
I WAS NEVER ASKED TO PARTICIPATE
IN ANYTHING POLITICAL.
I KNEW IT WAS HAPPENING AROUND
ME.
AMERICANS KNEW IT.
THAT IMPACT THE MISSION OF THE
BUREAU.
WE NEED THE BUY IN OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SUPPORT US
WHEN WE ARE DOING OUR JOB.
99% OF THE FBI EMPLOYEES ARE
WORKING HARD.
PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE
SACRIFICING.
MY DEAREST FRIEND AND ANOTHER
AGENT WERE SHOT.
DOES ANYONE ABOUT LAURA AND THE
OTHER AGENTS?
>> Sean: THE MEDIA ONLY FOCUSES
ON CASES THEY CAN POLITICIZE.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHEN
THERE ARE PEOPLE AT THE TOP THAT
ARE POLITICIZING THE FBI IS
TAKES AFRI THE AGENTS IN THE
FIELD TRYING TO DO THE REAL
WORK.
>> Sean: WE KNOW BECAUSE OF
GRASSLEY AND JIM JORDAN ALL OF
THE WHISTLEBLOWERS HAVE COME
FORWARD.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE YET.
YOU ARE THE FIRST PUBLIC ONE AND
THERE WILL BE MANY MORE.
THIS ARTICLE COMES OUT.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE FEEDBACK?
SOME POSITIVE?
ESPECIALLY FROM THE FBI?
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF AMAZING
INDIVIDUALS THEY WORKED SHOULDER
TO SHOULDER WITH ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AMERICA NEEDS TO KNOW THERE ARE
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE HOLDING THE
LINE.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY TO VOICE THEIR CONCERNS.
IT PUTS A TARGET ON YOUR BACK.
THERE MIGHT BE TIMES WHEN YOU
ARE NOT INVOLVED.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T
AAGREE WITH WHAT IS HAPPENING.
KEEP YOUR LOW AND STAY OFF THE
RADAR.
>> Sean: YOU WERE 8 YEARS AWAY
FROM A PENSION.
YOU GAVE UP A LOT.
>> FOR ME, I AM A WOMAN OF
FAITH.
I BELIEVE IN GOD.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I KNOW THAT GOD IS WATCHING
OVER ME AND THE AMAZING PEOPLE
IN THE FBI.
>> Sean: THIS WAS REALLY HARD IF
YOU?
>> IT WAS A DIFFICULT DECISION.
I SACRIFICED A LOT WORKING FOR
THE FBI.
I WANT AMERICANS TO UNDERSTAND
WHEN YOU GO TO AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITE AND SEE YOUNG CHILDREN IT
TAKES A TOLL.
MY PHONE WAS RINGING 247.
IT'S A SACRIFICE TO SERVE THIS
COUNTRY BUT WE LOVE AMERICA.
>> Sean: ARE COURAGEOUS.
WE WISH YOU GOD'S SPEED IN
FUTURE ENDEAVORS.
THANKS FOR YOUR COURAGE